merci madame la Présidente ma question
s'adresse à monsieur le ministre du
Travail du plein emploi et de
l'insertion monsieur le ministre ma
question porte sur les conséquences de
votre réforme des retraites pour les
métiers pénibles avec carrière hachées
en milieu rural en Corrèze territoire
fracturé par vos politiques successives
il y a beaucoup de femmes conjointe
d'agriculteurs qui après avoir élevé
leurs enfants comment se reprenne une
activité car le revenu agricole de leur
conjoint ne suffit pas à subvenir à
l'ensemble de leurs besoins de leurs
familles elles reprennent la plupart du
temps un emploi dans des métiers de
service le plus souvent comme aide
ménagère à domicile au service de nos
seniors ou agents de services en EHPAD
j'en profite pour préciser que les
agents de services en milieu médicaux
social font partie des oubliés du Ségur
de fait
en reprenant cette activité tardive leur
carrière arriver à 64 ans ne sera pas
complète pour pouvoir prétendre à la
pension minimum de 1200 euros pour tous
proposer initialement par le groupe LR
puis reprise par le gouvernement
monsieur le ministre ma question est
simple que diriez-vous à Cécile la gente
service à l'EHPAD de Neuvic en Corrèze
maire de deux enfants qui à l'âge de 64
ans aura travaillé 30 ans soit le 120
trimestres auquel ne s'ajoutent de
quatre trimestres par enfant au lieu de
8 dans le privé soit un total de 32
années de service une carrière
usante et pénible en travaillant
dimanche et jours fériés mais surtout
une carrière non complète quel sera le
montant de sa pension sera-t-il descend
[Applaudissements]